imagine Pinhead and Michael Myers  battling itself for Supremacy in a  cinematic crossover along the lines of  Freddy vs Jason or Alien vs Predator  Paul Kane's book The Hellraiser films  and their legacy reveals that filmmaker  Dave Parker once pitched this exact idea  for a movie two-dimension films to  establish a plausible reason for these  characters to brawl Parker suggested An  Origin story that would open with a  flashback in which Myers is  trick-or-treating as a child and  receives a mysterious box from a  stranger in black boots upon opening it  the lord of the Dead possesses Maya's  body and goes on a killing spree  Dimension was excited enough to reach  out to both Clive Barker and John  Carpenter and pencil in a movie release  date of October 31st 2004. however not  only did the owners of the Halloween  movie rights reject the idea a poll on  the official Halloween website suggested  that the majority of fans didn't want  the movie to happen at all so it didn't